dozens of blockbusters hit screens as
the millennium came to a close but only
a few received the acclaim necessary to
reach 100 on rotten tomatoes keep
watching to see which 90s hits made the
cut
the premise of 1991's only yesterday is
well-worn a single career-minded woman
discovers happiness and love outside of
the big city however this anime film
provides its own masterful approach
adapting the manga story of the same
title by hotaru okomoro and yukotone
with the adaptation helmed by iso
takahata the movie follows working
professional taika okojima as she leaves
tokyo to visit the countryside
reflecting on memories from her
upbringing but i was terrible at
fractions
sometimes i just wish that it had been
easier for me only yesterday came out at
a time when realistic dramas focusing on
women's stories were not commonplace in
anime like the manga source material
only yesterday is a frank and engaging
look at women's lives in modern japanese
society as tycho realizes how she wants
to live
the only real travesty behind only
yesterday is that the film did not
receive an official north american
release until 2016 a staggering 25 years
after its debut
acclaimed screenwriter steve zalian made
his directorial debut with 1993's
searching for bobby fisher based on the
1988 book by fred waitzkin the film is
focused on waitskin's chess prodigy son
joshua after fred discovers that his
young son is a naturally gifted chess
player he pushes him to hone his skills
creating friction between them their
relationship is tested as josh begins
entering national chess tournaments at
his father's urging with fred feeling
his son could become grand master bobby
fischer's successor
your son creates like fisher
he sees like him at its core searching
for bobby fischer is a story about
fathers and sons chess is only the
backdrop for the tale and does not
hinder the viewing experience for those
unfamiliar with the game beyond the
dynamic between josh and fred josh's
relationship with his chess mentor bruce
faces challenges of its own as the boy
learns the intricacies of the game
searching for bobby fischer is a
coming-of-age movie that appeals to
audiences of any age with a winning cast
delivering its paternal themes the 18th
century french revolution espoused
ideals of equality liberty and
fraternity the latter virtue was
explored in the 1994 film three colors
red the final film written and directed
by christophe koslovsky red is the last
installment of his three colors trilogy
true to its theme of fraternity red
follows deep friendships and connections
forged by different groups of people
throughout the swiss city of geneva
during the revolution red is vibrantly
brought to life by recurring crimson
imagery across its depiction of
flourishing friendships elevated by a
sentimental yet invigorating score by
composer zignif prizener red is perhaps
the warmest of the three colors trilogy
driven by its interconnected stories
this film would prove a bittersweet end
to kishilovsky's career as it was the
last film he made before his untimely
death in 1996.
three colors red fulfills the promise of
his ambitious three-part project by
saving the best for last
after helming a pair of well-received
comedies filmmaker richard linklater
turned his attention to the
possibilities of true love in an idyllic
getaway for his next project pairing
actors ethan honk and julie delpy 1995's
before sunrise saw their characters meet
by chance as they were passing through
vienna so listen here's the deal this is
what we should do you should get off the
train with me here in vienna come check
out the town developing an instant
attraction the two shared their thoughts
on a variety of subjects as they
wandered the streets of the austrian
city together set across a 12-hour
window before the two young lovers park
ways and return to their respective
lives before sunrise proves less is more
driven entirely by thoughtful dialogue
engaging chemistry between the movie's
charismatic leads and the viennese
backdrop the movie's no frills approach
works beautifully link later hawk and
delby would explore the lives and
spiritual growth of the characters they
created in two subsequent sequels that
were each met with similar acclaim
pixar animation studios is synonymous
with quality and academy award-winning
animation their iconic legacy began with
the studio's first feature film toy
story taking the simple premise that
sentient children's toys come to life
when humans aren't looking toy story
follows a cowboy doll named woody who
grows jealous after his owner requires a
buzz lightyear action figure it looks as
though i've been accepted into your
culture your chief andy inscribed his
name on me after woody and buzz come to
blows they must learn to work together
or lose their lives with andy forever
boasting an all-star voice cast led by
tom hanks and tim allen toy story
largely spearheaded american animations
shipped to cg feature films
more than just putting pixar on the map
as an eventual disney powerhouse many of
the animation industry's most acclaimed
figures were key parts of the movie's
production including john lasseter pete
doctor and andrew stanton spawning an
entire line of sequels and spin-offs toy
story remains the crown jewel in pixar's
film catalog pixar quickly proved that
it wasn't a one-hit wonder studio and it
caught lightning in a bottle again with
the 1999 sequel toy story 2. as the toys
settle into their new home woody is
discovered to be a rare antique he's
subsequently stolen by an unscrupulous
toy collector this leads buzz to
assemble his friends to stage a daring
rescue mission recovering woody before
he can be shipped off to a museum for
good simply put toy story 2 is a sequel
done right it goes bigger and bolder
with its premise and cast while keeping
sight of what made its predecessor so
effective lucky are you shrink wrapped i
am missing my arm the sequel inverts the
core premise of the original toy story
instead of woody trying to rescue buzz
buzz must now rescue his cowboy friend
toy story 2 dials up the action scope
and emotion delivering a pitch perfect
sequel that cemented pixar's place in
the animation industry check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
you